I'm in France,
right,
since eighty-six,
ma'am,
I have been in France since eighty-six.
I left my country
because like any,
like any man,
his dream is to come to France.
When I was in school,
in elementary school,
Congo,
I learned about the French Revolution at the age of 8,
Napoleon,
I learned this in school.
What you don't know,
us, in Africa,
eh,
in our schools, eh,
we were studying the French Revolution,
all that.
So we didn't know that,
we had already prepared you before coming to France.
Even the ministers,
the,
the rich,
they send their children to France to study,
to spend the vacations.
This means that Europe
promises us many things,
because when 1 wins,
he comes on vacation to Africa,
he brings back beautiful cars,
beautiful clothes,
all women,
it's his,
he buys houses,
then they don't tell the truth.
That's what he saw.
That all Africans,
dreams have become.
In France,
not long ago,
we heard on the radio,
on television,
there are the boats that were stranded.
The migrants,
they died in the sea to come here,
because it is their dreams.
When people take risks,
to pile up
in the boats,
100 people,
200 people,
It means that there is something strange here,
ma'am,
I'm lucky enough to sit down,
to fight here, eh,
many people,
they exceeded.
The money,
they moved heaven and earth,
but they did not arrive in France.